in the 16th century an Italian
mathematician named Cardno had a
well-known gambling addiction he wrote
letters in which he bragged about his
ability to beat his friends at dice
games his trick was to place his bets
using his ideas from mathematics instead
of hunches or luck he came up with a
method of calculating the exact
probability of random events such as say
rolling Snake Eyes it is based on a
powerful property card on Oh noticed
every outcome no matter how many dice
you roll is equally likely this allowed
him to calculate the probability by
developing what's now called a
probability space first he counts all
possible outcomes known as the sample
space for a single dice these are the
six possible phases then he defines the
event in question such as rolling a1
which can occur in one way the
probability is then found by dividing
the event by all possible events which
in this case works out to 1/6 realize
the cold calculating logic here there is
no such thing as a lucky number no
divine intervention the probability of
rolling any number is exactly 1/6 now
the same logic applies when we roll
multiple dice
imagine you needed to know the
probability of rolling a pair first he
counts the size of the sample space with
two dice rolls there are 36 possible
outcomes 6 times 6 then you count the
number of ways this event can occur
there are 6 different pairs so 6 divided
by 36 is the probability of rolling a
pair also 1/6 this simple yet powerful
idea allowed Cardinal to bet according
to the true probability while his
opponent's place their bets based on
hunches and lucky numbers remember this
works with multiple rolls
imagine we needed to know the exact
probability of rolling three ones simple
first we figure out the size of the
sample space for three dice this is 6
times 6 times 6 or 216 and there is only
one way to roll three 1s so the
probability is 1 divided by 216 this was
the trick it was not based on magic but
mathematics remember to calculate the
probability of a random event such as a
dice roll you divide the number of ways
that event can occur by all possible
outcomes